what do all iconic scenes have in common
and i'm not limiting this question just
to one piece or even anime and manga
seriously what unites any iconic scene
that you love
no matter if it's in a book a movie an
anime
or even a photograph the most
fundamental answer to this question
that i personally came up with is that
they all
manage to create real heartfelt emotion
and my reasoning for this answer is this
a scene can be iconic for a variety of
reasons right
because it's incredibly funny sad epic
horrifying heartwarming you name it
but in the end as diverse as these
moments might seem on the surface
on the most fundamental level stories
are all about making us
feel something we simply love losing
ourselves in fictional worlds and epic
adventures
because it allows us to experience
moments we could never have
in real life however as any aspiring
writer will know
actually creating authentic and
impactful emotions in a scene
is anything but easy the fact that oda
has managed to create
so many of these moments really speaks
for the
understanding that he has for his craft
and frankly without it
his story would probably never have been
able to run for as long as it has
as we will explore more and more
throughout this series of videos
the most iconic moments in one piece all
do an exceptional job at making us feel
a certain way
and many can undoubtedly be described as
tearjerkers
what i found truly fascinating about
this and i think you might as well
is that there is no one formula of how
to achieve this
and especially mangan anime have a
number of unique tools
therefore the scene we will be breaking
down today will be an
absolute master class in how to create a
strong emotional response in your
audience
it is one of the highlights of the water
seven and a slobby arc
which is coincidentally my favorite arc
in the entire story so far
i think you know what moment i'm talking
about well
mainly because it's in the title of this
video fair enough
[Music]
but i think even without that it would
probably have been easy to guess which
one i'm talking about
ugh goosebumps i'm really happy you guys
seem to enjoy this new series as much as
i do
cause i'm frankly having a real blast
re-reading and re-watching these scenes
and at the risk of sounding a bit cocky
it's also so much fun building an
entirely new format from scratch
that isn't out there yet so thanks for
sticking with me
and also thank you for sharing all your
amazing ideas and thoughts with me
okay but now enough sweet talk i think
it's time to go through some fields
again
so grab yourself a cup of coffee and
some tissues maybe
and let's get into this beauty of a
scene before we can get into the
analysis part
i will do a quick recap so if you want
to skip that you can simply jump to the
time code up here
and the corresponding chapters are
391-399
and for the anime it's episode 278
in case you want to read or watch along
the scene takes place at the height of
the ns lobby arc
the straw hats have fought their way to
the tower of justice and
start their legendary walk to anna's
lobby where they face robin and the
members of cp9
robin is shocked to see them here and
tells them that she won't return to them
and that she wants to die all to protect
her newly found friends
from the wrath of the world government
this is followed by robin's flashback
and the events of o'hara
where we truly get to know robin and her
true personality and dreams
for the very first time reliving her
tragic coming of age story
and all the hate rejection and betrayal
she had to endure
she fears that she will bring nothing
but unfortunate upon those around her
even though she clearly
loves the straw hats at this point and
what she fears the most
even more than death is to be abandoned
and betrayed once again
just as crocodile and so many others had
done to her before
at this point she truly has given up on
life
she once again warns spandom about the
horrors of the busta call
who carelessly threatens to use it on
the island and he asks robin
how anybody could ever not see her as a
burden when her enemy is the world
government itself
pointing at the flag on top of the tower
of justice
and asking luffy whether he truly
understands
who he's actually facing here luffy
however
coldly replies that he understands very
well who robin's enemies are
and without so much as a hint of
uncertainty
he orders usopp to shoot down the world
government flag
towering over the island usop steps
forward
and burns down the flag while all of the
straw hats watch with stoic faces
and with this the straw hats have now
officially declared war on the world
and thus taken away robin's reason for
protecting and rejecting them
and then luffy tells robin to say that
she wants to live
recalling her tragic past sal's final
words to her that she will surely find
nakama one day
and finally usopp asking her to trust in
luffy
she finally breaks free of her mental
prison and shouts her dream
[Music]
after this moment frankie also declares
his love for the straw hats and destroys
the plans for the pluton
and then the bridge lowers and the straw
hats as well as cp-9
prepare for battle okay so what makes
this scene
so special how's oda able to create such
an intense amount of emotional response
with this moment here
there are a couple of things i want to
get into but the most fundamental
element i believe
is emotional contrasting
what makes robin's words here so
powerful
is not the words themselves but the
chain of emotional sequences
leading up to that moment at the outset
of anna's lobby we have grown to more or
less accept robin as a part of the crew
she has traveled with the straw hats to
the sky islands and established a rather
nice presence on the ship
however her character is still shrouded
in much mystery
and neither we the reader nor the crew
really
knows whether it's okay to fully trust
her as an ally yet
her abduction by the cp-9 is kept
purposefully ambiguous biota
where we only slowly learn that
something is happening against robin's
will here
luffy is the only one that truly seems
to understand her
right from the start his unique ability
to sense a person's true character and
their intentions
might even have been the reason that he
saved her from the tomb in alabast in
the first place
he must have been aware right from the
start of all the pain and sorrow that
robin had been carrying in her heart
and knew that she was looking for a
place that she belonged
thus he immediately takes his crew and
follows her to ana's lobby
to take her back knowing that this is
what she truly wants
and so even if we don't know about
luffy's ability at this point
seeing our main character disinvested
and determined
we simply can't help but become involved
into robin's rescue as well
this is followed by the cruise raid on
the island and their fight against time
before robin is ultimately shipped away
through the gates of justice
where she will be forever out of reach
this
builds enormous urgency and raises the
stakes for every single moment during
the arc
leaving us on the edge of our seats
whether or not luffy will make it in
time
at the same time seeing his newly gained
abilities with gear 2
gives us some hope that this is actually
a battle that might be won
the epic walk to n's lobby and the
determination of the crew to get their
nakama back
is a pure firework of euphoric shivers
for me
however this is immediately countered by
robin's sudden anger and her declaration
that she wants to die
we can kinda tell here that there is
something more going on
that she does indeed want to be saved
but why in the world does she behave
this way
and this is when we finally get the
flashback into her past
the harsh and lonely childhood she had
how she lost the only place that ever
accepted her
and how she had been on the run from the
world at large for her entire life
having no one to turn to confronted with
in my opinion the most
tragic backstory of any straw hats we
get
punched in the gut with a wave of
sadness pity and
dawning comprehension of who robin truly
is as a person
suddenly we understand her character
fully and it makes the events until now
and the current situation just the more
impactful and engaging
[Music]
now me stopping the clip right at this
moment
might have made you twitch a little or
maybe even felt a bit annoyed
wanting to see what happens next how
robin reacts to this
this is the type of engagement you want
to reach as a writer when it comes to
capturing your audience
this moment is charged with anticipation
and emotion
and is what makes it so memorable you
simply can't help yourself but wanting
to see
what happens next and this is of course
what makes robin's words
the ultimate catharsis after building up
the tension towards the scene for
countless chapters
while at the same time setting the mood
for the second half of the arc and the
fights that will follow
so at this point we are 110
involved in this mission to save robin
and want to see our heroes succeed
against
an also amazing cast of antagonists
now moving on to the scene itself one of
the things that stood out to me the most
here
was the crazy amount of symbolism it
contained
in general oda loves filling his story
with symbols and references
some are small and arc specific while
others span the entirety of the story
and so there are some rather obvious
symbols here
like the walk to the tower which
directly references the walk to alan
park
or usopp shooting down the flag which is
generally known to be a declaration of
war throughout history
but for instance the flag itself also
symbolizes a lot here
the world government as a whole and the
political system behind it
it represents the power of the world and
the weight it has
towering over the entire island and more
specifically
over robin thus burning it down does not
only mean the straw hats declaring war
in the world
but it also symbolizes the influence
that the world government had on robin
vanishing by burning her doubts and
fears to ashes
the fire itself meanwhile is therefore a
literal
light in the darkness for her as she
finally accepts and understands
that luffy and the crew truly have come
solely for her sake
and with no ulterior motive she is truly
able to trust someone again
for the very first time since losing her
home
i think the anime does an especially
wonderful job here at visualizing this
showing her leaving behind her darkness
and going into the light
fantastic visual symbolism here where
she finally is able to join her friends
with
all she is this transition also includes
another symbol of water 7 and nslobby
overall
masks what they represent is pretending
to be someone you're not
and literally putting on a false face we
can see this used with frankie
the cp9 and of course with usopp
but robin in many ways also is putting
on a mask throughout the arc
trying to push luffy and the others away
and so in this scene
luffy metaphorically breaks that mask
and she's able to show her true face and
true intentions
finally being able to be the person that
she really is
thus the i wanna live moment stands in
direct contrast
to the i wanna die moment just a little
earlier
really hammering home the impact that
the straw hat's actions and words have
had on her in just a small amount of
time
she has now fully accepted that she's
actually worth something
and that she's worth to be cared for and
rescued by her friends
meanwhile the golden snail held by
spandom and the destructive buster call
it can summon
symbolized robin's traumatic childhood
and all her suffering that she had to go
through
by having to experience it and finally i
think it's fair to say that the tower of
justice itself
also is a symbol the name seems to be
quite ironic at first
since it seems to show the hypocrisy and
twisted sense of justice of the world
governments
however with oda putting in another
twist here
at the end of the arc the tower of
justice has actually lived up to its
name
as robin truly does get what she
deserves
freedom a new family that loves her and
a place that she belongs
i would actually say that it's a bit
cheesy but that stuff
is just so damn powerful damn you oda
now how is the character's body language
and the dialogue in the scene implements
it
well i think the portrayal of robin's
emotion speaks pretty much for itself
the facial expressions and the conflict
within her are wonderfully drawn by oda
and the anime also does a great job at
capturing her emotional transformation
here the way that she's finally able to
cry
and let out all these emotions that she
had suppressed for so long
are simply overwhelming to see and
beside that
i think the scene also manages to really
bring out her inner dialogue
in a very believable and convincing way
here giving us some crucial insight into
her inner world
next to robin i think the scene also has
some wonderful language for the other
straw hats
of course there's luffy whose intense
and emotion-filled speech towards robin
is one of the most important moments for
his character arc in my opinion
giving us some of these occasional
moments where luffy's true capabilities
as a leader
come clearly to light and what about the
other straw hats you might think
well i think i have rarely seen a mong
or anime
do such a fantastic job with silence
as this scene does because none of the
straw hat says
anything they don't address robin they
don't cry out in shock when luffy tells
usop to shoot down the flag
they don't show fear or anger or really
any sign of emotional effect this moment
could have or
maybe even should have on them no they
decide to simply
stand there next to luffy side by side
with a
stoic and determined look on their face
radiating
nothing but pure confidence and trust in
their captain
and dedication to getting their friend
back sadly
show don't tell is an important skill in
storytelling
that somehow is heavily underused in
animated manga and i feel especially in
shonen where often
everything is explained so everyone in
the audience can really get what's
happening right now
but i think this is a perfect example
how powerful
silence can be and simply letting the
visual speak for itself
just watch
[Music]
this is what gives me goosebumps i don't
need everyone in the crew to say out
loud that they really want to save robin
this is the way to do it and to get me
on board with the scene
finally next to robin i think it's also
worth mentioning the change we see in
some other characters in this moment
in terms of body language and dialogue
frankie for instance finally completely
changes from antagonist to ally in this
moment
being deeply moved and showing his true
colors as well as his affection for the
straw hats here
this results in him destroying the plans
of the pluton
and fully following into the steps of
his beloved master tom
who worked for the former pirate king
roger during his time
a quite overlooked moment i believe and
then there's of course spandam who
changes from a sense of superiority and
arrogance
to fear and panic once the flag is taken
down
and while his character might be
annoying beyond help it does
a wonderful job at getting us fired up
for his defeat
and also shaping luchi to be the way
cooler and more threatening antagonist
of this arc
and speaking of luchi his face in the
scene
goes from indifferent and annoyed to
full
ecstasy and bloodthirst something that
hypes up the second half of the ark
and his later encounter with luffy even
more
the scene is also heavily accented by a
great use of sound effects and music
the flag of the world government flying
heavily in the wind
the silence as usual shoots down the
flag the sound of the flames mixing in
with robin's tears
as well as the music when robin finally
breaks free
are all greatly chosen and do the scene
justice i think
also special props here to luffy's and
robin's voice actors
both of which do a wonderful job here
carrying the heavy emotions in the scene
with their performance one thing i think
is not
quite optimal here though is spandom's
voice acting
i'm not quite sure why that is but i
think there was just so much more
potential here to portray him in a more
unpredictable and threatening way
compared to the mostly comic voice that
we get for him in the end
just a small side note now the last
thing i want to look at
is the framing in the scene in general i
think
anna's lobby has great framing and
camera movement overall
however there are some things that
really stood out to me
the scene opens up with a wide shot of
anna's lobby
showing the literal and metaphorical
chasm between robin and the crew
isolating her from her friends i think
this
is quite purposefully done here and i
simply love the effect it has on the
reader
and in general of course the entire
island's theme
is focused heavily around these
monstrous structures here
showing the power of the world
government and giving the stage an epic
feel
thus when showing anna's lobby even
smaller before the enormous gates of
justice with the world government's icon
on it
and when robin says that no one's ever
allowed her to follow her own dreams
the giant iron gates tower threateningly
over the entire moment the same goes for
the government flag that spanden points
up to
overlooking the entire scene as a sort
of protective force
and also i'm a big sucker for this panel
here
where the straw hats stand at the edge
of the abyss absolutely
fearless staring down the cp9 and the
way that the cp9 members
mirror that pose in just the same way
creates a fantastic sense
of balanced opposition and contrast not
only does it foreshadow the battle
but it also foreshadows the similarities
between both groups with
the cp9 being a quote-unquote more
evil version of the straw hats and last
but not least
luffy's and robin's matching close-up
shots with
robin answering her captain's call and
fully becoming part of his crew
beautiful so what is the overall purpose
of this scene
and how does it fit into the context of
the story well of course anna's lobby as
an arc overall
plays a major role in building the world
and driving the story forward
but focusing on just this one scene here
i think that if there is one thing in
particular it achieves above all else
is that it gives major development to
four of the straw hats
robin luffy usop and frankie
let's look at this list from last to
first you know
so we can have some more dramatic ending
to this video
storytelling so let's start with frankie
there is not too much focus on his
character in this sequence
and yet in retrospect it is fairly
obvious that oda is
already shaping frankie to become a
straw hat here
witnessing this incredibly emotional and
powerful moment between the straw hats
serves as a sort of breaking point for
him where he also is finally able to
drop his mask
and show his emotional and kind-hearted
real sight declaring his love for the
crew by
burning the plants of the pluton before
spandems and the cp9's eyes
he really mimics luffy's declaration of
war on the government
and thus also qualifies himself to join
them at the end of the arc
in general i believe that frankie's arc
here in nslabi is quite underrated
which is to be expected i guess when
it's overshadowed by robin's incredible
storyline
but nonetheless i think it's important
to appreciate how subtly oda manages to
turn his character around in this moment
then of course we have usopp the
entirety of ennis lobby serves as usop's
redemption arc after defying luffy and
leaving the crew on water 7.
while there are many moments that are
important to his re-establishment as a
member of the straw hat crew
like on the sea train with robin or late
at the port this scene here
where he without hesitation follows
luffy's orders to declare war on the
world
might be the most important for him in
terms of symbolism and impact
he shows us that he now fully accepts
luffy as his captain
and makes another step to becoming a
brave warrior of the sea
and while the flag scene is definitely
anything but underrated
the role that uso plays in it definitely
is i believe
next we of course have to talk about
luffy
as mentioned before i believe that his
speech here at the tower of justice
is one of the best moments for his role
as captain of the crew
oftentimes luffy shows his thoughts and
emotions through actions and fighting
here however he actually finds the exact
right words
one would expect from a captain and
future pirate king
and it's one of the moments i always
remind people of
whenever they say that luffy is not a
good leader because the point here is
that luffy is becoming a good leader
and it's moments like these that show
this growth
when it counts luffy can lose his
nativity and easy-going nature
and become serious and it's moment like
this one here
or the one where he gives nami his hat
where i think
most of us gain the most respect for
luffy as a main character
and that already brings us back to robin
the way that oda shows her moment of
liberation in this scene
and how he builds up all that emotion
and suspense for a character
is simply one of my favorite moments in
one piece
and the reason that this clip easily
deserves a spot in the series of videos
robin in this moment becomes a
full-fledged straw hat
and her development from alabaster
until this moment is one of my favorite
character arcs of all time
robin breaking out of her depression and
seeing how saul's words have come
full circle is a powerful moment to
witness
she now finally has found a place that
she belongs to
after losing the scholars on o'hara and
for the first time she's able to really
fully
trust someone else and so in this moment
robin is prepared to live life to its
fullest
now while luffy's speech in this scene
is incredibly touching and powerful
coming from the hero of our story i
think it's quite surprising that another
iconic moment in one piece
is another speech however it doesn't
come from luffy
or any other of our heroes but from none
other than the main villain of the story
blackbeard's speech on jaya and so we
will be discussing this iconic moment
in the next video so stay tuned for that
thanks guys
peace